michael good to see you um this is quite
a ballsy move given everything going on
uh it's not i mean we think there's a
lot of pent-up demand there for summer
holiday travel
uh clearly that won't take place in
april may but we do believe that by june
july august
there would be reasonably free movement
of people within the between the uk and
the european union and vice versa
you look at the success of the uk's
vaccine rollout program by the end of
march 50
of the adult population would have been
vaccinated by the end of june that rises
to almost 80 percent
i think it'd be very difficult for
either the uk government or the eu
governments to lock people down once
you've 80
of the adult population vaccinated but
do you really think that people
are going to want to book while there is
this risk of being made to stay in a
quarantine hotel for a fortnight
well we don't think that we think that
risk will disappear by the time we get
to june july and august
uh there is in through april going to be
a significant
increase in the volume and production
volume of vaccines
and so i think there's a lot of hysteria
you know there's a 24-hour news cycle at
the moment feeding all this hysteria
we're still only in the middle of march
and i think the situation would have
changed markedly by the time we get to
june july august when people the kids
are on holidays
we're rolling out 26 new routes today
from the uk to europe to destinations in
greece portugal spain
and we do believe people will are they
are making bookings we know that at the
moment but they're making bookings
safe in the knowledge that we allow them
to change those bookings
without any change fees not once but
twice if their plans change during the
summer
yeah you are offering zero uh change
fees but the changes have to be made
seven days before flying i mean given
the uk government's track record in
putting countries onto the red list at
48 hours notice
is that necessarily going to be a
sufficient uh get out for them
i think people will know frankly weeks
months in advance if you take the
government's own guideline at the moment
you know they're saying no international
travel before the 17th of may
uh but we will have i think they're
going to update the markets in the
middle of april
you know we're reasonably confident that
there will be unrestricted
holiday travel for british families
going to european
beach resorts in portugal spain the
canaries the lyrics
in june july and august this year well i
sincerely hope you're right i mean uh
what are you hearing on the ground from
continental europe at the moment there's
a lot of
interest obviously in the success of the
uk vaccine rollouts you have governments
in spain
portugal greece cyprus uh already
announcing that
uh they're going to remove restrictions
on uk arrivals from the 17th of may
onwards
that might move back if there's some
movement in vaccines or further travel
restrictions but there's no doubt in our
mind
that the spanish hoteliers the
portuguese the greeks are looking
forward to welcoming
certainly uh british families who have
been vaccinated
and most of will have been vaccinated by
the time we get to the school holidays
in june july and august so
i think we should be calm we should be
reasonably uh confident and optimistic
i'm not saying they're definitely going
to go ahead
but i think there's a reasonable
prospect higher than 50 percent that uk
families will be
holidaying in june july and always this
year in spain greece portugal as normal
and uh what about uh this issue of
refunds
are you braced for a deluge of them if
the government does suddenly start to
change the rules
we are i mean you know we've processed
over a billion and a half in refunds and
uh vouchers over the last 12 months
we've completely eliminated the backlog
of
refunds there are still tiny numbers
still stuck in
people who booked through unauthorized
uh screen scrapers
who were still trying to deal with but
other than that
direct customers have received all of
their refunds or vouchers
a lot of people are using those vouchers
now to rebook summer travel
and summer holidays this year uh but we
think it will be
to the extent that we will have to make
further changes during the summer
either by adding flights or removing
flights we're now handling that kind of
within 24 hours or reasonably seamlessly
online
one thing that uh jumped out at me
looking at the new routes that you're
unveiling today eight of them are from
uh belfast city
you're back in george best belfast city
airport for the first time in 11 years
we are again we saw an opportunity there
you know belfast has suffered grievously
during the last 12 months particularly
with the demise of fly be
uh and to a lesser extent thomas cook
but flybe was a big operator in belfast
city airport we see an opportunity to go
up there
there is significant demand for european
travel from belfast
and funny enough we think a lot of
people from the republic of ireland are
going to use these flights
as a means of escaping to portugal
greece and italy
in the earlier part of the summer even
while ireland's uh
vaccine program lags considerably behind
the success of the uk program
that's very interesting well you've made
my director very happy because he's a
belfast lad so uh that's good
uh what about uh uh passenger duty
you've got
um the uk government indicating
yesterday it's gonna cut it on domestic
routes
is that a big kicker potentially for you
i think it could be i mean it would be
certainly one of the ways of uh
i think stimulating the regional
airports
who have suffered again you know the
loss of flight b is very damaging to the
regional airports
i think particularly if they were to
reduce the apd
which is a scandalous tax on air travel
on domestic routes
you would see a large boom in flights uh
domestic flights to and from scotland
and northern ireland to the rest of uh
the uk but any we've been calling now
for
about six nine months for the repeal of
apd at least for a two or three year
period until such time as air travel
volumes go back to their pre-covet
levels
you know rishi sumac has been very
successful with the help of eat out to
help out
with those various schemes nothing has
been done for aviation and the way to
get people
visitors back to the uk is going to be
to scrap uh the
apd tax particularly on short haul
european routes
until at least you get back to the
pre-cover traffic levels
now look before i let you go you had a
fantastic win at cheltenham last week
with
tiger roll but you've withdrawn him from
the grand national has he retired now
no no he's withdrawn from the grand
national because he's completely
unfairly weighted
i think there's every prospect that he
will run in entry
uh we're looking at the betfair bold
three-mile grade one chase
so that we can prove to the handicapper
in the uk that he is completely unfairly
handicapped
uh he should be dropped in the weights
and then
if he stays fit and well hopefully he
might come back for uh
another run at the grand national in
2022
all being well and hopefully at that
stage we've all passed by the colvin
crisis
you are always battling the authorities
in one way or another aren't you
what can i say they have it in for me
michael good to talk to you as ever take
care thank you